vamos a intentar uno difícil este es un
clásico tenemos dos cargas una de ocho
nano culos positivos y otra de menos 8
nano culos y en lugar de preguntar cuál
será el campo eléctrico en el medio a la
mitad lo que sería esencialmente un
problema en una dimensión nos vamos a
preguntar cuál es la magnitud y
dirección del campo eléctrico neto
creado en el punto p aquí tenemos un
problema en dos dimensiones ya que
queremos encontrar la magnitud y
dirección del campo eléctrico neto que
está aquí arriba vamos a comenzar a
resolverlo de la misma manera ambas
cargas van a crear un campo eléctrico
aquí arriba que va a tener cierta
dirección esta carga positiva crea un
campo eléctrico que tiene una dirección
radialmente lejos de ella y radialmente
lejos de esta carga en el punto p pues
será algo más o menos así a este campo
eléctrico le vamos a llamar la el azul
porque es creada por esta carga positiva
azul y mi carga negativa
también va a crear su propio campo
eléctrico en este punto que va
radialmente hacia adentro de esta carga
y algo que radialmente se dirige hacia
esto va aa verse más o menos así y este
es nuestro campo eléctrico
amarillo ya que es producido por nuestra
carga eléctrica negativa de color
amarillo muy bien hasta aquí usamos la
misma aproximación pero ahora las cosas
se empiezan a complicar un poquito
observen esto estos campos ni siquiera
apuntan en la misma dirección se
encuentran en este plano bidimensional y
nos piden encontrar el campo eléctrico
neto y lo que vamos a hacer para
resolver estos problemas de campo
eléctrico bidimensional es descomponer
cada uno de estos elementos es decir el
campo eléctrico generado por esta carga
positiva va a tener una componente
horizontal más o menos así que va a
apuntar hacia la derecha y que vamos a
llamar el azul x porque es el componente
en x generado por esta carga azul y este
mismo campo eléctrico va a tener un
componente verde
qué vamos a llamar el azul que apunta
hacia arriba y de forma similar el campo
eléctrico creado por la carga negativa
va a tener un componente horizontal que
también va hacia la derecha y que vamos
a llamar x amarilla y también tiene un
componente vertical pero este va hacia
abajo y es el componente que llamaremos
a de amarillo y ahora qué vamos a hacer
con todos estos componentes para
encontrar el campo eléctrico neto bueno
lo que típicamente hacemos en estos
problemas de dos dimensiones es
enfocarnos en encontrar los componentes
de estos campos eléctricos en cada una
de las direcciones por separado así que
dividimos para vencer cual es el
componente vertical del campo eléctrico
neto y cuál es el componente horizontal
de este campo eléctrico neto y ya que
encontramos ambos podemos combinarlos
usando el teorema de pitágoras
si queremos para encontrar la magnitud
de este campo eléctrico neto analicemos
nuestro problema tener
y cierto tipo de simetría aquí y cuando
tenemos cierta simetría nos podemos
ahorrar algo de tiempo a qué me refiero
bueno ambas cargas tienen una magnitud
de 8 nano cool oms y ya que este punto p
se encuentra por encima del punto
intermedio entre estas dos cargas la
distancia entre la carga positiva y el
punto p va a ser la misma que la
distancia entre la carga negativa y este
punto p estas dos cargas crean un campo
eléctrico en este punto que tiene la
misma magnitud que es simplemente
apuntan en direcciones diferentes es
decir que esta carga positiva va a crear
un campo eléctrico que va a tener un
componente vertical que va hacia arriba
una cantidad positiva que no conocemos
en este momento pero sabemos que es una
cantidad positiva ya que esto apunta
hacia arriba y nuestra carga negativa
crea un campo eléctrico que tiene un
componente vertical que apunta hacia
abajo es decir tendrá signo negativo
pero será de la misma magnitud que el
componente vertical
del campo eléctrico de la carga positiva
es decir el componente vertical creado
por la carga positiva tiene la misma
magnitud hacia arriba de lo que tiene el
componente vertical del campo eléctrico
creado por la carga negativa hacia abajo
así que cuando sumamos estos dos
componentes verticales para encontrar la
componente vertical del campo eléctrico
neto vamos a tener cero se van a
cancelar por completo lo cual es bueno
porque solo tendremos que preocuparnos
por los componentes horizontales estos
dos no se van a cancelar ya que ambos
como pueden ver están apuntando en la
misma dirección si uno de ellos apuntará
a la derecha y el otro hacia la
izquierda
entonces si se cancelarían pero como
ambos están apuntando hacia la derecha
no se van a cancelar estos componentes
se van a combinar para crear un
componente horizontal total en la
dirección a la derecha para nuestro
campo eléctrico neto y su magnitud será
mayor que cualquiera de estos
es más va a ser el doble de grande ya
que cada carga crea la misma cantidad de
campo eléctrico en esta dirección
debido a la simetría que encontramos
aquí así que reducimos este problema a
encontrar solamente el componente
horizontal del campo eléctrico neto y
para hacerlo necesitamos encontrar los
componentes horizontales individuales de
cada uno de estos campos eléctricos
tengo que encontrar el componente
horizontal de mi carga positiva que hará
una contribución positiva a mi campo
eléctrico neto ya que esto apunta hacia
la derecha y a esto le agregamos el
componente horizontal del campo
eléctrico amarillo el cual también
apunta hacia la derecha aún cuando la
carga que está creando este campo
eléctrico es negativa
el componente horizontal es positivo
porque va hacia la derecha
tengo que encontrar ambos componentes
para encontrar mi campo eléctrico neto y
como encuentro estos componentes
horizontales para encontrar
componente de este campo eléctrico azul
primero necesito encontrar cuál es la
magnitud de este campo eléctrico azul
conocemos la fórmula para esto la
magnitud del campo eléctrico azul es
igual acá por q / r al cuadrado para mi
campo eléctrico azul es 9 por 10 a la 9
por la carga que es más 8 nano cool oms
nano es igual a 10 al menos 9 y la
dividimos entre la r pero cuál es la r
en este caso no es 4 y tampoco es 3
recuerden que la r en esta fórmula
eléctrica siempre va desde la carga
hasta el punto en donde queremos
encontrar el campo eléctrico así que r
es esto y como encontramos esta
distancia y estamos de suerte ya que si
conocemos un triángulo 345 aquí tenemos
que este lado mide 3 este otro lado mide
4 automáticamente sabemos que este lado
va a medir 5 metros pero
si no se sienten seguros con respecto a
esto siempre pueden usar el teorema de
pitágoras para encontrar r que sería la
hipotenusa cuadrada más b cuadrada es
igual a c cuadrada para cualquier
triángulo rectángulo que es el que
tenemos aquí a este lado 3 b es este
otro lado que es 4 y r sería este lado
así que aquí ponemos el real cuadrado
sumamos los cuadrados que serían 9 más
16 esto nos da r al cuadrado sacamos la
raíz cuadrada lo que nos da 5 como
habíamos dicho anteriormente pero si ya
conocen los triángulos 345 pues se
ahorran tiempo porque ya saben que este
lado siempre va a ser 5 y esta es la r
que vamos a usar aquí así que aquí
ponemos 5 al cuadrado y si hacemos
nuestros cálculos nos va a dar que esto
es igual a 2.88 newtons colom ésta es la
magnitud del campo eléctrico creado por
esta carga positiva que pusimos en color
azul
en este punto p y como encontramos el
componente horizontal
de este campo eléctrico hay varias
maneras de encontrarlo una de ellas es
encontrar primero este ángulo de aquí ya
que encontrando este ángulo podemos usar
trigonometría para encontrar este
componente de aquí como encontramos este
ángulo pues vean que este ángulo base en
el mismo que tenemos aquí estos son
ángulos similares ya que tengo líneas
paralelas y una diagonal que va de aquí
acá así que si encuentro este ángulo de
aquí voy a encontrar el ángulo que está
aquí arriba como encuentro este ángulo
pues aquí conozco cuánto miden cada uno
de los lados de este triángulo así que
podemos usar seno coseno o tangente para
encontrar este ángulo vamos a usar la
tangente y digamos que la tangente de
este ángulo siempre se define como el
opuesto entre el adyacente el lado
opuesto a este ángulo es 4 metros y el
lado adyacente es 3 metros así que la
tangente detecta es igual a 4 tercios
como encontramos ate cta bueno pues
decimos que teta es igual a la tangente
inversa de cuatro tercios
básicamente aplicamos la tangente
inversa en ambos lados de esta igualdad
nos queda teta a la izquierda y si esto
lo calculan les dará 53.1 grados y este
es el ángulo de aquí 53.1 grados lo que
quiere decir que este ángulo de aquí
arriba también es de 53.1 grados ya que
quedamos que ambos son el mismo ángulo
noten que este componente horizontal de
aquí no es igual que la componente
horizontal de aquí abajo que mide tres
metros y este componente diagonal de
aquí tampoco es igual a esta diagonal de
cinco metros pero el ángulo que se forma
entre estos dos componentes es el mismo
ángulo que se forma entre estos dos de
aquí abajo que hacemos para encontrar
este componente horizontal este es el
lado adyacente al
por lo que vamos a usar coseno de este
ángulo el coseno de 53.1 grados es igual
al lado adyacente que es
x el componente horizontal dividido
entre la magnitud del campo eléctrico
total aquí es la hipotenusa de este
triángulo que es 2.88 por lo que
x va a ser 2.88 nano cool oms
multiplicado por el coseno de 53.1
grados y si escribimos esto en nuestra
calculadora nos va a dar 1.73 newton
colom esta es la cantidad de campo
eléctrico creado por esta carga azul en
la dirección x este es el valor de este
componente de aquí 1.73 newtons colom y
para encontrar el componente horizontal
de nuestro campo eléctrico amarillo que
fue creado por nuestra carga negativa
amarilla pueden hacer todo esto de nuevo
o pueden notar que debido a la simetría
este componente horizontal es
exactamente igual al componente
horizontal creado por nuestra carga
positiva así que ambos tienen el valor
de 1.73 y ambos son positivos porque
ambos están apuntando a la derecha así
que la magnitud del campo eléctrico
total en la dirección x será de 1.73
la carga positiva más el componente
horizontal de mi carga negativa que
también es 1.73 y tenemos que el
componente horizontal de mi campo
eléctrico neto es igual a 3.46 newton
colom este es el componente horizontal
de el campo eléctrico neto en este punto
básicamente tomamos estos dos valores y
los sumamos o lo que es lo mismo
tomamos uno de estos y lo multiplicamos
por dos y quizá les preocupe que este
sea solamente el componente horizontal
del campo eléctrico neto y como
encontramos la magnitud de el campo
eléctrico neto pues será el mismo valor
ya que aquí no tenemos un componente
vertical así que el componente
horizontal va a ser igual a la magnitud
de todo el campo eléctrico neto en este
punto si tuviéramos un componente
vertical de este campo eléctrico neto
tendríamos que usar el teorema de
pitágoras para encontrar la magnitud
total del campo eléctrico neto pero ya
que sólo teníamos componentes
horizontales porque estos componentes
verticales se cancelaron entre sí el
campo eléctrico total va a apuntar hacia
la derecha y será igual al doble de uno
de estos componentes horizontales que si
los sumamos nos da 3.46 en newton colom
esta es la magnitud de nuestro campo
eléctrico neto y la dirección va a ser
directamente a la derecha en resumen
cuando tienen un problema de campo
eléctrico en dos dimensiones dibujen el
campo eléctrico creado por cada una de
las cargas descompongan cada uno de
estos campos en sus elementos
individuales si existe alguna simetría
vean cuáles componentes podrían
cancelarse y para encontrar el campo
eléctrico neto el componente que no se
cancela y calculen la contribución de
cada una de estas cargas en esta
dirección
sumen las o resten las con base en cuál
es la dirección a la que apuntan estos
componentes hacia un lado o hacia el
otro
esto nos va a dar nuestro campo
eléctrico neto en ese punto creado por
nuestras dos cargas